well back in May when bill de blasio
launched his ludicrous presidential
campaign he had a lot to say about
working people in fact he counted
himself among them as president I will
take on the wealthy I will take on the
big corporations I will not rest until
this government serves working people as
mayor of the largest city in America
I've done just that I'm bill de blasio
and I'm running for president because
it's time we put working people first
it's really weirdest plus posture looks
like he left his hanger in a suit jacket
I will not rest deep pledged that turned
out not to be true in fact the one thing
you can be certain de Blasio is doing
resting according to a new report in the
New York Post for the entire month of
May bill de blasio spent a total of
drumroll please
seven hours at work running New York
City at City Hall not seven hours per
day seven hours total
chef Barron lives in New York City where
he's an associate at City Journal he
joins us tonight
that's not my I mean look I'm not as hip
as I used to be I'm not sort of current
with what is considered hard work I
guess but seven hours in a month that's
still considered slacking right even in
New York it's not all it's not a full
day's work but you know I mean Tucker
Tucker to be honest you know everyone
I've talked to about this says oh well
that's good the less he's here the less
damage he killed us right that's Pell
Grant we should have sent him away why
didn't he run in 2016 look this is a man
who considers it a normal thing to go in
mid morning and take a fleet of
limousines to Brooklyn to go to the gym
and sort of desultorily stand on the
elliptical and you know pedal in the
middle of the the middle of the Working
Day for most people and then go get a
pastry this is a guy who's reported to
take naps during the middle of the day
you know his campaign has been a
disaster from the beginning when he went
to Trump Tower and made some absurd
announcement and people were parading
behind him with worst mayor ever signs
you know then he he went down to Miami
he quoted Che Guevera it's it's it's a
joke it's I remember speaking to a new
york city cop retired who had been
around his security detail who said that
their Gracie Mansion was redolent of
marijuana smoke with one the deblasio's
were there do you think that's maybe
part of it well look I've heard this too
it's kind of a common theme around City
Hall and around the press and and so
forth whether it's true or not I don't
know but it certainly it would explain a
lot
it would explain a lot it would explain
a lot and here we just thought it was
laziness and a slow metabolism but it
turns out America's worst mayor is bad
because he's really high I mean he may
not be the worst mayor in New York
history only person since 1900 only
since 1908 or you know a setback great
to see you tonight
thank you thank Stoker